welcome back so i'm really excited today to tell
you about one of my absolute favorite topics
in fluid dynamics and dynamical systems in general
which is how to extract these lagrangian coherent
structures from fluid flow data specifically
using the finite time lyapunov exponent
so this is one of my absolute favorite topics
uh when you know one of the first things i got
interested in in fluid mechanics were these ftle
fields and these beautiful flow visualizations
of kind of unsteady flow structures kind of
analogous to invariant manifolds from classical
dynamical systems so even back when i was an
undergraduate this really caught my attention
uh and i loved just looking at these videos and
kind of trying to understand how flows evolved
from from from these coherent patterns and my
first projects in graduate school were essentially
on how to compute these quantities so i'm really
excited today to walk you through what these
coherent structures are how we compute them using
these finite time leopon exponent fields i'll
give you plenty of examples of how we use these to
understand ocean mixing how you know jellyfish eat
unstudy aerodynamic applications and we'll talk
about how to actually compute these in practice
so this video i'm showing you right here is
essentially an airfoil or a wing that's plunging
up and down in an incoming flow so flows the fluid
flow is going from left to right and this wing is
plunging up and down and these lyapunov exponent
fields that's literally what's plotted in blue
here is the finite time lyapunov exponent it's
a quantity that you can plot in space and time
and it shows when the flow is separating
when you get a large leading edge separation
and it demarcates this rich wake structure that's
generated by this airfoil so you can use this to
understand how lift and drag are generated for
things like helicopter blades or a fish swimming
through through the ocean and we've known for a
long time that there are these coherent structures
that kind of emerge from complex fluid flows
there's a wonderful book by milton van dyke called
an album of fluid motion with you know over 100
pages of beautiful flow visualizations like this
that show the coherent structures in the wake
of objects so this is a circular cylinder again
flow is going from left to right and this is
visualized using a classic technique called
smoke visualization it's as simple as it sounds
you take a wind tunnel you put the circular
cylinder in the wind tunnel and you put a stick
of incense or a cigarette or something else that
generates smoke upstream and you see where
that smoke kind of accumulates and outlines
and highlights this rich rich wake structure
which is known as a von carmen vortex street
and so that's been used for decades this smoke
visualization to outline these coherent structures
in the wake of fluid flows and the finite time
lyapunov exponent is essentially a quantifiably
rigorous way of doing that from data so we
can quantify uh objects like these and how
you know how fast the smoke is accumulating
and things like that from flow field data
i'll point out you know we have all kinds of
examples of coherent structures in nature in
technology that emerge in these complex flow
fields so this is the atmospheric flow of
clouds over guadalupe island one of my favorite
visualizations of coherent structures and again
you can see very clearly just like the smoke
visualization this is a cloud visualization where
you can see the the vortex street forming behind
this and so we would like a kind of rigorous uh
way of numerically computing these
coherent structures from data like this
even in our art if you look at van gogh or davinci
kind of our intuition of fluid flows is centered
around these coherent patterns and coherent
structures and so we would also like it if the
patterns that pop out of this
lagrangian coherent structure analysis
were somehow consistent with our intuition
for what the essential building blocks
of a flow field are things like vortex you know
cores and sheer layers and things like that
and i really really like this image as kind
of a motivation so we're going to get into
the technical details in a little bit but i love
this visualization from a recent review paper by
george haller who is one of the pioneers of
this field of coherent structure extraction
i'll highlight this paper a little bit later
but just to show that in you know lots of exotic
flows like the uh atmospheric flow on jupiter
you have these persistent coherent structures
like the great red spot or these you know very
very rich sheer layers um and these lagrangian
coherent structures or lcs give us a way of
kind of quantifying or demarcating different
regions of the flow that behave differently or
that are somehow separated from each other good
uh and this is just a teaser of some of the
applications i'll be talking about so i'm going
to talk about unsteady aerodynamic applications
things like you know wind turbines or wings moving
we'll talk about how this relates to mixing
in the ocean and even this really really cool
example of how a jellyfish feeds understanding
uh this feeding process using these finite timely
opponent of exponents okay so now it's time to
dig into kind of how these things are computed
what they mean more mathematically and then we'll
go back and revisit those applications at the end
okay so i'm going to go back to this flow
field from the intro this is one of my favorite
visualizations i made during my phd thesis for
uh kind of understanding plunging motion at
a low flow velocity or over a small scale wing
and what we're going to do here is essentially
in general we're thinking about the fluid flow
as a dynamical system uh given by this this right
hand side vector field u of x and t so u is the
unsteady fluid vector field this could be a vector
of quantities u v w for the x y and z components
of the velocity if you have a three-dimensional
fluid flow or this could be a two-dimensional
vector field if you have a 2d flow like this one
and notice that this vector field so at every
point in space x the flow points in a direction
that means that this is a vector field and that
vector field is unsteady because it's changing
in time clearly you can see this movie the
vector field the fluid is changing in time
and so what we're going to be thinking about
with these finite timely open of exponents
is how do passive particles move along this fluid
velocity field that's the thought experiment we're
going to be looking at so we're going to consider
the position of a particle x so i'm going to drop
a particle here we're going to imagine that it's
kind of passive neutrally buoyant it just flows
along with the flow and we're going to follow
that particle along the flow and see where it goes
and by looking at neighboring particles
and finding regions where those particles
separate the most in forward time or in backward
time we're going to be able to highlight these
very very cool kind of structures using these
motions of passive particles and i'm going to
have you know a whole lecture series on how to
derive these equations these kind of fluid flow
equations on the right hand side how to think
about passive particles advecting along these
these fluid flows but for now you know we're
going to just kind of assume that we know how to
integrate particles along those vector fields so
if you have an initial condition x naught so some
particle position at time zero you can essentially
integrate its position along this fluid velocity
field to find out where it will be at some later
time t x of t and the way they do you would do
that is essentially through a numerical time
stepping scheme like a forward euler integration
or a runge-kutta integrator you would take your
initial condition x naught you would compute the
vector field at that position at time knot and
based on that vector direction you would step
your particle one delta t forward in time now at
that new time there is a new velocity field this
velocity field has changed both in space and in
time because i'm at a new point in space and a new
point in time and so now i use that new vector
direction and i take another step and then at
that point i take another step and essentially
you integrate along this unsteady vector field
to get your position at a later time t this is you
know in math it's kind of a complicated expression
if you have uh data for this vector field or a
function it's relatively easy to integrate in
matlab or python using whatever numerical scheme
you like so we're going to call this the flow map
which essentially takes an initial condition at
time 0 and maps it forward to a final position
at time t okay and we're going to denote this
by big "Phi" for the rest of this presentation.
So what we're going to do now is we're going
to take a grid of particles ,a whole uniform
grid of particles, we're going to map them all
forward through time. We're going to integrate
all of them through this flow field and we're
going to try to find regions where they stretch
the most. That's going to highlight
these regions of large Lyapunov exponent.
Lyapunov exponent is just a term from
classical dynamical systems that quantifies
how much very close particles spread
through a chaotic flow field in time.
So schematically that's what we're doing:
we're taking a grid of initial particles,
we're mapping them forward through this flow
map, and notice that they all get kind of
distorted and stretched out. And we're going to
look specifically at how neighboring particles
stretch and deform through this flow map.
Regions of high stretching and deformation
are going to be outlined as bright
bright blue regions in this FTLE field.
Really important, and sometimes I forget
to say this... this is super important:
if you have this flow field, you can integrate
particles forward in time or you can integrate
particles backward in time to see where they came
from. Both of those give you important information
about this Lyapunov exponent field. In fact
these blue regions here that I'm highlighting,
I actually computed these by taking my grid of
particles and integrating them backwards in time.
So particles that stretch a lot in backwards time
tend to be accumulating material in forward time.
That's what smoke visualizations do, they
take smoke and they accumulate that smoke into
these very thin wake lines. So to get the
equivalent of smoke visualization movies,
that are very intuitive to us humans, you actually
take your grid of particles and integrate them
backward in time. So i'm going to talk about both
of these: integrating particles forward in time
and integrating particles backward in time to find
out where neighboring particles stretch the most
in forward or in backward time. And the reason
I care about regions that stretch the most in
forward and backward time is because that gives us
a direct analog of unsteady and steady manifolds,
but for these time varying vector fields.
Stable and unstable manifolds for these time
varying vector fields. So that's what i'm
showing here. Again this is the flow field
for a fixed wing at a constant angle of attack.
Fluid is going from left to right and here I'm
integrating particles forward in time; here
I'm integrating particles backward in time.
And you can see these two FTLE sets here that are
illuminating different regions of the flow field,
and this is a really interesting point... often
times these finite time Lyapunov exponents have
really high values or ridges, kind of mountain
ridges in the flow field. That's what I'm
visualizing here in red and in green. And you'll
notice that particles that start inside this red
region stay inside particles that started
outside kind of whizzed by and stayed outside
and so these red ftle ridges are almost like
invariant manifolds where the particles can't
pass through them so particles that stay
on one side of this invariant manifold
that start there stay there and particles
that start outside will also stay outside
similar for the reverse time structures and so
that gives us a direct analog of these stable
and unstable manifolds for uh for the classic
dynamical systems that don't vary in time
okay and stable and unstable manifolds is one
of the most important ways that we understand
non-linear differential equations so if you
have a nonlinear differential equation like this
you might look for the fixed points linearize
about the fixed points to find some eigenvalues
and eigenvectors so you might see if it's a stable
fixed point or a saddle point and then you would
take the eigenvectors associated with those
eigenvalues and those will essentially give you
subspaces where the dynamics are invariant and if
you continue along those subspaces you'll sweep
out these manifolds where if you start on one
side of the manifold you stay on that side forever
which is really really useful it's a way of
kind of segmenting your your phase space uh
into different coherent regions and the finite
timely opponent exponent calculation gives you
a direct time varying analog of these stable and
unstable manifolds but for unsteady flow fields
so it's really useful in carrying all of our
intuition from dynamical systems over to these
time varying fluid systems and that's why people
love to use these so much because there's a ton
of intuition we have from classic dynamical
systems theory and again here i'm going to talk
more about these papers later but these are kind
of the two main papers i think of when i think
of lagrangian coherent structures and finite
timely open up exponents related to manifolds
good now it's a little uh maybe counter-intuitive
why the unstable manifold in red that's where you
know if i started a little bit to the left or
right of my fixed point i would go out forever
why do those attract particles in forward
time right it sounds like they should be
repelling particles forward time it's a little
counterintuitive but the way i want to think
about this is if i have two particles kind of
on the left side of this green stable manifold
at up and down right where my hands are in
forward time the stable manifold is going to
push them towards the unstable manifold and then
along the unstable manifold so you can actually
picture that particles do tend to get closer and
accumulate onto the unstable manifold they almost
shrink wrap onto the unstable manifold in forward
time and so that's why i painted these structures
here red these forward time attracting structures
are essentially analogs of the unstable manifold
because particles or smoke visualization smoke
will accumulate onto these red ridges in forward
time and similarly these backward time structures
are analogous to my stable manifold these are
points that kind of diverge in forward time or
collect particles in backward time if i reverse
time my unstable manifold would become stable
and my stable manifold would become unstable good
and i cooked up this little visualization to kind
of show what i mean here so again this is just a
saddle point a classic saddle point the green
are my kind of stable manifold the red is my
unstable manifold and if i have these little kind
of blobs of fluid here and i i kind of march them
backward in time you see that if i
reverse time they squash along these
uh this stable manifold this green manifold
and so that's actually what i would do i'm
going to restart this visualization
so what i actually do to compute this
this red manifold or this green manifold is i take
a bunch of particles i integrate them let's say
backward in time so remember arrows are going this
way so if i integrate them backward in time things
go the other way and i try to find regions
where they stretch the most in backward time
that will illustrate these these red lines
so for example things along this red manifold
will stretch the most in forward time as
they stretch along this the screen manifold
now this is a little bit of a kind of tricky
concept to wrap your head around you'll have to
really think about where particle goes in forward
time and in backward time to convince yourself of
how of like which direction you should integrate
to compute the red and the green structures
now you can do that and kind of overlay these for
this this uh airfoil example i was showing you
earlier and you see that there's this kind
of time-varying set of unstable manifolds
that determines all of the fluid transport in this
uh in the system and i want to point out again
saddle points from dynamical systems are
super important for understanding how energy
efficient transport happens so for example i am an
inverted pendulum or an inverted double pendulum
which has one or two saddle points and i use the
unstable direction of that saddle point when i
want to walk forward efficiently i kick myself
in the unstable direction the instability carries
me almost for free energetically and that's how
humans walk that's how we design efficient space
missions to jupiter and that's how if we were
for example traversing the ocean we might use
these time varying saddle points to to jump on one
side and get carried away by the unstable manifold
so these this idea of an unstable saddle is
super important for these time varying systems
okay good um so now i'm going to
go into a little bit of the history
talk a little bit more about nuts and bolts
of computation and then give some examples
this entire idea of these lagrangian coherent
structures and how to use these finite timely app
and have exponents came out of this seminal paper
by george haller in 2002 it's a fantastic paper
so i highly recommend you you read it where
essentially he showed how you would compute these
kind of objective lagrangian coherent structures
from velocity field data if you had data from a
system how would you compute where these invariant
manifolds are and and we say lagrangian because
the traditional methods essentially just looked
for regions of high vorticity or things like that
like you know tornado cores in your flow but if
those were moving along in a time varying fashion
those techniques didn't work very well and this
is more robust one of the things that was really
important about this paper is that essentially he
showed you could apply this to noisy vector field
measurements from experiments even if you had some
outliers or some bad measurements or some noise on
top of your velocity field you would still get
robust estimates of these coherent structures
because they're somehow persistent and because
you're integrating particles through them and
that generally smooths over a lot of numerical
inaccuracies in your flow field so really good
paper kind of the leading paper starting this all
off another one i really used a lot when i was
getting to know finite time we open of exponents
is this great paper by shannon leckian and marsden
where they essentially showed how to compute these
things they gave lots of examples um they talked
about how these lagrangian coherent structures or
those ridges of finite timely append of exponent
are material lines they're kind of these barriers
or these unsteady invariant manifold analogs
and they computed these using data uh you know
in real physical flows like this is the flow
off of the coast of florida and they computed
these separators where if you were on one side
if you dumped you know whatever something
here it would stay here for a long time
whereas if you you know released particles
here they might flow out to the ocean
really important paper these are kind of
the two big ones and then recently george
haller wrote this fantastic review paper in the
annual review of fluid mechanics on lagrangian
coherent structures i highly recommend you read
this it's got some of the best visualizations
and descriptions it's one of the the best annual
reviews i've read and again it talks about how
there are these kinds of analogs to classical
dynamical systems you know chaos and kam theory
but for these time varying fluid flows using
these lcs okay so really important stuff here
if you're interested in kind of reading about
the history of these things now i want to tell
you about how to compute these things at the end
of the day i you know love numerix i love actually
computing things from data and a lot of my career
has been focused on how do you actually compute
these finite time liability of exponent fields
quickly efficiently accurately from data so i'm
going to walk you through the steps and then we'll
talk about what they mean and how to interpret it
okay so if you have some fluid flow in my case
i'm always thinking about these air foils at low
reynolds numbers and some big angle of attack
that's given by this little white line here
what you're going to do is you're going to drop a
grid of particles a uniform grid of particles that
covers the area you're interested in and you're
going to integrate that set of particles forward
in time or backward in time using this flow map
that we talked about earlier so that's essentially
step one initialize the grid of particles flow
them all forward in time or backward in time
and now what you're going to do is for every
single point in that grid i've zoomed in on
this little white point here you're going to
look at that point and its nearest neighbors
and you're going to see how those nearest
neighbors got deformed after that flow map
okay and in general this is just a cartoon but
in general what you're going to have is you're
going to have some directions where they stretch
a lot some directions they might contract and they
might also rotate and for an incompressible
fluid flow kind of the area of this diamond
should be the same as the area of the deformed
diamond okay that's for an incompressible fluid
flow that's kind of an idealized case but the area
should be preserved before and after this mapping
it's a good numerical check you can do when
you're computing these things so okay at
every single point in this grid there is some
deformed set of neighbors they tilt and stretch
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
compute an approximate jacobian or derivative
of that flow map with respect to delta x and delta
y okay so i'm going to walk you through this this
is a little bit hairy but what we're doing here
is we're approximating the derivative of that flow
map or the sensitivity of that flow map to small
perturbations by literally computing the finite
delta x okay so this first term here is delta x
at final time divided by delta x at initial time
so i literally compute this delta x between these
blue points divided by the initial delta x between
these blue points that's the first element here
then i compute the delta y of these final points
divided by the delta x of those initial points
okay that's the second term this first red term
is the delta x of these red points so the kind
of x spacing between them with respect to the
delta y of these two red points and then this
final term here is the y difference between these
two red points this delta y divided by the initial
delta y what this is this is like the crudest
finite difference derivative approximation
of the partial of the first component of the
flow map with respect to x the partial of the
second component of the flow map with respect to
the first component with respect to y the partial
of the second component of the flow map with
respect to x and the partial of the second
component of the flow map with respect to y
bit of a mouthful even worse in three dimensions
but you get the idea i'm basically taking these
grid of particles this data i'm integrating
them forward and i'm approximating the finite
difference partial derivatives using these deltas
these finite width deltas and this is uh that
whole ugly expression written in coordinates
in case you're a masochist you can compute this
thing for every single point all of these white
points i can compute this little matrix okay
and this matrix of jacobian derivatives is
going to be different at every point here
if i have a lot of stretching and deformation at
one point i'm going to have a jacobian that that
exhibits a lot of stretching in that component
and so the eigenvectors and eigenvalues of this
jacobian of the flow map is basically going to
tell me along what directions am i stretching
the most or contracting the most and by how
much again for incompressible fluid flows
this should have a determinant of one
or approximately one numerically good
okay so the last step is so we float all these
particles forward now we've computed uh the flow
map jacobian at every point this is an expensive
computation because i might be doing this at 100
000 points now at every single one of those points
i take the largest eigenvalue of this matrix times
its transpose now you could just take the largest
singular value of this matrix that's the same
exact thing so the maximum singular value of this
uh jacobian flowmap jacobian basically says what
is the maximum amount i could possibly stretch
from this particle if i moved epsilon away from it
so if i was at this particle and i moved
a teeny little epsilon in any direction
where would i stretch the most what would be the
maximum stretching i could get that's given by
this lambda max of this delta quantity here or the
maximum singular value of this flowmap jacobian
and the last step is that you take the logarithm
of the square root of that and divide by the
integration time big t these are basically just
scaling it so that you can plot them and they
look nice but really it's this quantity here
this lambda max that you care about okay and
i realized i'm missing uh right parentheses
here so we can just pretend that it's there
okay let's take a big step back and summarize here
so at every single particle we've integrated it
forward in time computed a finite difference
derivative matrix to see how much that that
neighbors are stretching at that point and we pick
the maximum amount of stretching that could occur
and that is this value sigma the
finite time we have on an exponent
and there is a value of sigma for every single
point on this grid that's why it looks like a
flow field is because there's a finite timely open
of exponent value at every single point in space
it gets worse because that was just one snapshot
of a movie the next frame in the movie i have
to reinitialize this grid reintegrate all of
those particles forward recompute all of these
quantities and that's the finite time we happen
of exponent at the next time step of the movie
and the next time step i have to do it again
and again and again so this is an extremely
expensive computation to integrate all of these
particles starting from every initial time
step of your movie forward in time and computing
all of these quantities but if you can do this
this finite time liability of exponent field
will tell you where in space will i get the
most stretching forward in time that's a very
useful quantity again because it tells you
what what regions are analogous to these stable
and unstable manifolds and let me see if i can
get this right if i wanted to compute the stable
manifolds which repel particles in forward time
i would integrate particles in forward
time and find the maximum stretching
if i wanted to find the unstable manifold those
red manifolds that attract particles in forward
time i would actually integrate my particles
backward in time and find the largest backward
time ftle because again if they stretch a lot in
backward time they attract a lot in forward time
makes a lot of sense okay good this is the one
slide overview of how to compute ftle i'm going to
make more videos where we actually code this up in
matlab and python for some examples i'll also tell
you in future videos about how you can massively
speed this up by removing redundant calculations
that was kind of the first paper i ever wrote was
in speeding this up when you're computing this for
a movie of ftle fields good okay and going back to
this picture here now i think we're finally ready
to really understand uh what these mean so the red
ridges these are values of largest finite timely
app on of exponent there are other values but i'm
plotting this on a log scale so only the biggest
values show up in red and these are finite time
weapon of exponents that i actually computed by
integrating particles backward in time so these
red ridges diverge the most in backward time
which means that they actually show how particles
converge in forward time they give me this
kind of smoke visualization
coherent structures that i want
and again they are analogous to these
manifolds that separate particles if you
start on the outside you stay on the outside if
you start on the inside you stay on the inside
similarly these green uh manifolds here
these green finite timeline of exponents
are computed by integrating particles forward
in time and finding where they stretch the most
and that gives me this stable manifold that
again attracts if you integrate in backward time
good and uh our analog here so one of the cool
things about this is that this applies equally
well to data from experiments from particle image
velocimetry measurements you can literally shine
a laser sheet in your wind tunnel with uh some
you know neutrally buoyant illuminated particles
and you can use those vector fields
to compute these coherent structures
you can also compute them from the vector fields
you get from direct numerical simulations from big
computer simulations which is
where i spent most of my time
and now i'm just going to walk you through
some of my favorite examples of of these
quantities so this is one of my favorite papers
by melissa green clancy rowley and george howler
where they showed that you could apply this to
full three-dimensional flow fields turbulent flows
uh in this case in this channel flow they showed
that you get these really really cool uh what
are called hairpin head vortices they kind of
look like little mushroom head vortices that
are climbing out of the boundary layer wall and
they showed that this uh this channel flow is
kind of riddled with these hairpin vortices that
are really nicely outlined and isolated kind of
uh extracted using these
lagrangian coherent structures
another one i really like this is from that review
paper by george haller but taken from this prl
paper originally where they had kind of a table
top experiment a circular dish that was being
excited to exhibit turbulence and you can see that
these lagrangian coherent structures the forward
and backward time the repelling and attracting
lcs outline this incredible template for how
mixing occurs in this turbulent fluid and again
if i wanted you know if this was a model of the
ocean and i wanted to get from point a to point
b i would probably try to use the saddle points
and try to navigate these saddle
points for energy efficient transport
and i'll try to put a link to a video
by my phd student karthik krishna
who is using kind of these coherent structures
for optimal navigation in ocean flows
good okay so a few more applications that are near
and dear to my heart again we've already talked
about these unsteady fluid dynamic applications
where you have airfoils pitching and plunging
again this is a lot like what the blades of
a helicopter do as they are going around in
a circle they pitch up when they're advancing i'm
sorry they pitch down when they're advancing and
up when they're retreating to balance the loads
and so this gives us a lot of understanding
of how those separated structures and wake
structures might impact the lift and the drag
i generated these from numerical
simulations from codes by tyra and colonias
and you can do things like look at
the actual forces on these objects
as these flow fields are evolving you
can look at the lift and the drag forces
kind of as different vortices are being formed
and shed uh on these these wing structures and
so you know i've spent hours and hours looking
at these trying to understand how could we model
these lift and drag forces by you know the
coherent structures being generated in the wake
okay you can also use this to understand real
devices like uh wind turbines you know vertical
axis wind turbines if you knock them over in
the water they're called cross flow turbines
this is work with ben strom who is a phd
student formerly with brian pelagi and myself
and this is a laboratory expel experiment in
brian's lab where we have a two-bladed turbine
in a water channel and we were doing control
experiments to try to increase the power output
of this turbine and so from flow visualization
like this you can essentially extract these
lagrangian coherent structures and get a lot of
rich information about how the flow field evolves
what are the the stable and unstable manifold
structures for example you see this beautiful
shear layer structure on the uh being shed
from the upper blade and this more classic
wake kind of structure from the lower blade and at
different turbine parameters these might interact
in different ways so very very useful to get a
more holistic picture of the structures being
generated by your your turbine and this
is especially important if we want to put
a downstream turbine in the wake and
try to harness some of these structures
so what we really want to do is we want to have
an array of these cross flow turbines or these
vertical axis turbines and we want to understand
where would we putt them to optimally exploit
these coherent structures in the wake good okay
um this is absolutely my favorite video whenever
i talk about lagrangian coherent structures in my
class i always show this video um it blew me away
so this is how jellyfish eat a paper by shaden
de beery and marsden 2006 you have to read this
and essentially what they did was they estimated
the flow field around this jellyfish and there
have been subsequent experiments where you
know they actually have an underwater piv laser
to collect measurements of this it's very
kind of high tech cool stuff and what they
do is based on that velocity field they compute
if i was a passive particle where would i end up
getting integrated along the vector field of the
jellyfish so this jellyfish is moving its its uh
i guess tail area here to create a propulsive wake
and what's really interesting is as it creates
its propulsive wake it actually is entraining
material into its inner bell where it digests
and so you can see this red lagrangian coherent
structure here very clearly outlines regions
where if you start on one side you stay
on that side so a blue region stays blue
but eventually this blue packet is going to get
entrained or sorry this one's going to get ejected
but the green packet here is going to actually get
entrained into the wake into the inner bell region
so i just love this video because it shows kind
of simultaneously how a jellyfish is creating
a propulsive wake by blowing all of this blue
momentum out from it and it's also entraining
fluid into its bell so it's swimming and eating
at the same time and that's made very very clear
by these finite timely opponent exponents uh
this is another kind of really cool extension
where dabiri and parker essentially use these
ideas to create this robotic jellyfish so this
is an actual i believe heart tissue from a rat
with these little pacemaker cells on this octagon
and they put this in an electrolyte solution
that they can pulse and essentially they
can create this pulsing muscle motion
you'll see it in a moment that mimics
yeah this external pacing when they turn it on
it's going to mimic the motion of that jellyfish
again you know you can kind of understand this by
those coherent structures how it would actually
propel itself just beautiful work really really
cool stuff um one of the areas that this has
been applied to the most is in understanding
mixing so this is a flat plate airfoil that's
moving up and down in a still fluid just kind
of mixing it up and you can see these attracting
lagrangian coherent structures these attracting
ridges of finite timely apparent of exponent
are essentially demarcating these regions of
mixing in this flow field and i'll i'll point out
when i say lagrangian coherent structure i usually
mean a ridge of this finite timely appointed
exponent field so this is the original vorticity
field just how much it's it's locally swirling
this is the attracting finite time layout of
exponent we obtain this by integrating particles
backward in time and this is the repelling set we
obtain by integrating particles forward in time
and you see that the kind of ftle fields
give you a lot of additional information
that you might not get just from this vorticity
field so for example at two different phases of
of this plate going up and down you can see that
there are these very distinct regions a b and c
that demarcate kind of different packets of
fluid that will stay coherent at least for
one period of plunging oscillation and similarly
you can see fluid that will about to be entrained
or about to be entrained into the left vortex
or the right vortex and if you start following
these particles around kind of like in that
jellyfish movie you can start getting a lot
of insight into how the mixing is occurring in
these flows okay good this has been applied a ton
to understand mixing in the ocean unfortunately
a lot of our study of unsteady dynamical systems
comes from understanding where pollution goes in
the ocean it's really kind of a human tragedy that
so much of our time is spent thinking about where
to dump stuff or oops we dump stuff where is it
going to go so for example in monterey bay there
are these very strong material lines where if you
dumped stuff on one side it would just recirculate
in the bay for a long time whereas if you dumped
it on the other side it would get ejected out
into the ocean and mix better similarly you
can understand for example the gulf of mexico oil
spill using these kinds of coherent structures so
whether or not it's a good or a bad thing it's
quite interesting that you can understand a
lot about mixing and transport in the ocean
using these lagrangian coherent structures
uh and this is a picture that philip
dutois made when he was a phd student
with jerry marsden i love this this picture
that shows kind of this full global scale
lagrangian coherent structure computation
so you can see just all these rich rich patterns
uh in the kind of you know earth weather systems
very cool stuff okay good and i think i
mentioned that you compute these quantities
these these lagrangian coherent structures as
the ridges of finite time weapon of exponents
one piece i really want to point out
here that i think is super important
is that these finite time lyapunov exponent fields
tell you a lot about where your flow is the most
sensitive to perturbations and this is super
important if you are interested in control theory
so you know again we're going to be looking at
this analog of an unstable saddle point where
you know particles kind of flow from one uh one
manifold to the other in forward or backward time
and so if i have uh some position x where i'm
at in my flow field and i add a perturbation to
it you can essentially tailor expand how
that particle will flow forward in time
and the perturbed particle will be near the
original particle at some later time t plus
this amplification factor and this amplification
is given by the flow map jacobian dotted with
this perturbation epsilon and this is going to be
largest at regions where the finite time the open
of exponents largest so where the ftle field is
the biggest is where you have the most opportunity
to affect your flow with small perturbations
so i've heard melissa green say this before
that these ftle ridges are kind of
where if you put order epsilon energy in
you can get order one out after some finite
time and that can be really really useful for uh
this is also a very useful expression for
numerical analysis just to analyze what
happens in these flow fields these these
taylor expansions can be quite useful
okay um parting thought the way that we computed
these lagrangian coherent structures 10 years ago
was we would compute a finite timely app
on our exponent field like i showed you
we would take the logarithm and there would be
ridges and then we would act actually compute
the ridges of that ftle field using
some kind of a ridge tracking algorithm
you'd look for places where there's you know zero
derivative and highest curvature and you basically
pull out the ridges of the ftle field and that
would be the lagrangian coherent structures
recently this paper by mohamed farizman and
george haller showed that there is a better way
of computing those lagrangian coherent structure
ridges from your ftle field using a variational
theory so this will take a little bit too much
time for me to unpack here maybe i'll do a video
on this in the future but if you're really serious
about computing these ridges this is the algorithm
you want to use again still based on the finite
timely append of exponent but just a better way
of computing these lagrangian coherent structures
from those ridges uh some important things
i like didn't really have too much time to get
into there's there's this could literally be like
a whole class on lagrangian coherent structures
is that these ridges of ftle these values of high
stretching highly append exponent sometimes
that stretching of particles occurs because
the particles are stretching perpendicular to
these blue ridges sometimes the stretching is
happening because of shear roll-up and technically
the lagrangian coherent structures you want
are the ones that are perpendicularly shedding
or kind of normally hyperbolically shedding those
are the ones that give you kind of the analog of
these stable and unstable manifolds okay so there
will be more videos about how to compute these
things how to code these up how to do it more
efficiently for movies like this one maybe we'll
dig into kind of how that sensitivity analysis
looks uh for real flow fields and how you would
use this for control theory all right thank you
you